I saw the monster and it creeped the
hell out of me and that was too much for
me to handle but I taking a break I'm
ready I'm ready to do this ready to face
my fears uh-huh and I don't have much
oil left barely anything at all and I
don't have many tinderboxes left so I
feel pretty screwed here I must say that
I hope
and I found out what straying means I
didn't realize that in the last in the
last video I was like what Alice strain
I I have to get out of here apparently I
really need to find tinderboxes that's
what I need oh thank god
come on pick it up Danielle look at me
here make a noise
come on pick it up oh my god Oh annoying
all right I got it god I just need some
oil now
[ __ ]
don't stray that was what I supposed to
do which it means don't go oh Jesus I
thought he was gonna come in here
oh [ __ ] ah this game is not friendly not
friendly at all [ __ ]
all right let's debris this 22nd of June
8th huh it's been more than a month
since my last entry after the event
inside the underground chamber in
Algeria professor Herbert insisted I
returned to England he said he didn't
want to risk forfeiting the entire
expedition lest I took a turn for the
worse
an excessive decision in retrospect but
I'm glad it turned out that way I found
my journal this morning in the haphazard
collection of things brought home from
Africa next to it laid a broken stone or
wrapped in cloth a try to assemble it
but couldn't the pieces wouldn't fit
together as if they weren't from the
same object
imagine little was there ever a complete
all hmm
I'm [ __ ] all about we're talking
about lettuce or something yeah there it
is
that oil
I really need to save in my own
you really really need oil oh gosh I
just don't want to bump into him
but it feels like they know I know when
you're the most scared so he's gonna pop
up them
oh I'm out of oil with Betty [ __ ]
dude you prove health do I have health
customers what though I didn't know
you're gonna know all right I need that
it's in here
I bet that she's gonna go in here
all right
light I'll take that
this Allah
I in here
all right I think we're good
don't want into oh thank god okay yeah
oh I really really needed that it's not
can use my lantern again all right
Sonny oh geez Fidel
ah I guess I got to take one of those
okay I see
but don't walk in those weights my
health
what's in here tinderbox and you
I need as many of those so I have
all right oh don't look him that I was
blood
let's see what this is about barrels
there
all right that bits on the other side
there are barrels there so I kind of
feel like I shouldn't go in there but
this is [ __ ] do this
all right
we're good for now
help at least [ __ ]
this gave me more skater now I have to
tell that it was not very scary for a
while and then I boil thank you
where did I come from don't remember
not to getting lost wasn't that one of
the things he wanted me to do all right
they're gonna head back to that thing
Franklin
let's let's read our notes or whatever
I forgot how I bring that up though
there we go notes
no no diaries
now mementos throw won't pull the hatch
open something must be clogging the
pulley it's a pulley
huh there it is right
ah there we go
all right Russell salt
don't sneak up on me I'm just uh
it's a man
all right you know no wrong way oh it is
open up yeah oye going down there why
not does it look scary huh let's see if
I can do this without loosing any help
all right we're down here hold that it
that is I had better lace in this one
all right you can do this I'll need my
ladder right now don't walk in the
disgusting goo
all right
okay let's go in here he crashed through
the surface dark Atlantic waters smother
him as he struggles to make sense of the
situation so am i lit this up for me
it's pretty weird
sup with that noise oh jeez what was
that
no I was so lit up but like that sad
face
I was water oh he's my lantern yeah yes
get up
God what the [ __ ] was that
holy crap okay I'm gonna end part I
can't keep forgetting what part is part
7 I think seeing part 8 [ __ ]